troisième volet de notre page d'été
consacrée à l'excellence à la française
nous avons réuni tous les ingrédients
jean hartling maîtres artisans d'art et
meilleur ouvrier de france
son domaine d'excellence la cristallerie
d'art c'est le reportage que nous vous
proposons nous sommes dans une salle
d'exposition touré de cristal et vous
jouer au golf
vous ne doutais de rien non pas du tout
c'est un défi que je me suis lancée il
ya plusieurs années il fabriqué des
potter du golfe avec la du cristal et
donc il est composé donc d'une masse en
cristal noir d'un grip en ébène donc
toutes sortes de bois précieux plus un
contrepoids qui est le pommeau en
cristal clair ce qui permet d'avoir un
équilibre pour jouer c'est une pièce
d'exception
c'est un défi que j'ai eu à plusieurs
années
et quand j'ai commencé à en parler aux
amis il montre était pratiquement le fou
de faire un peu peur en cristal qui dit
cristaldi casse comme du verre c'est le
cas de le dire
et ce défi je voulais le relever prouvé
qu'on pouvait faire un peu tard en
cristal et s'en servir et jouer
il est ainsi jean arctique rien ne le
stimule davantage que les missions
impossibles
il est le seul à fabriquer ces potter en
cristal que des pièces uniques
cet ancien ingénieur l'institut du verre
est un alchimiste
je vous montre un travail débauche une
étoile au fond d'une pièce faut pas se
tromper parce que on procède par
enlèvement de matières qu'on ne peut
jamais remettre mon travail consiste à
tailler donc sculpter la matière
première pré définis à l'aide demeure
pour arriver de la matière brute au
stade de crystal brillant donc là vous
avez une ébauche brut
la matière première semi finis ensuite
on fait un traçage pour avoir des points
de repère pour faire la ciselure une
fois les bausch fête on à ce stade et le
stade final vous avez sa leçon du
cristal à l'heure actuelle dans le monde
de la cristallerie d'art les principales
entreprises qui fournissait de la
matière première pour nous les artisans
ont disparu je jette l'épongé pour
certaines fabrications par manque de
matières premières faut changer comme
moi le fusil d'épaulé je fais les
peut-être je fais des boules l'escalier
encore la restauration
ça va très bien et vont la recherche et
l'écriture sur le verre qui meublent pas
mal les journées maintenant après ce
reportage nous retrouvons notre invité
c'est en 1967 que jean arthuis qui a
créé sa cristallerie tard dans cette
salle d'exposition nous avons des pièces
magnifiques et notamment
ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est c'est
injuste de style du nommé montgolfière
qui ont été créés au 19e siècle qui par
beaucoup de résidences princières et
royales et hot manoir cette salle
d'exposition est un émerveillement pour
les yeux voici rassemblés la
quintessence du savoir faire de cette
crystal reed à cette taille gravure là
qui est dû à un arrière grand père qui a
créé ce modèle du temps de l'empereur
françoise françois josef et
l'impératrice sissi gelé intitulé si si
mais c'est vraiment une marque de la
maison mon grand père le frère et mon
père le fils et j'ai continué à le faire
jean arthuis qu et c'est un signe du
destin est né à dakar à d'une lignée des
verriers qui remonte à 10 750 en bohême
pas étonnant qu'ils cristallisent tous
les superlatifs
maître artisan et meilleur ouvrier de
france
à une époque j'avais 160 modèle de
service de table qui était diffusé à
vaiges avait des gens qui étaient
décorateur qui diffuse aussi sur une
table votre maître mot c'est l'exigence
la qualité et du très haut de gamme
pourquoi ce choix
c'est par tradition dans la famille on a
toujours travaillé dans le haut de gamme
si vous voulez et puis
c'est un choix à faire s'il nie comme ça
donc tu en es à bakara qui est une
grande marque et dans l'autre grande
cristallerie je me suis cantonné dans ce
sens ce créneau qui permet de travailler
seul lieu de faire la fabrication
semi-industrielle je vais préférer
rester dans le métier d'art merci de
nous avoir reçus dans ce très bel
endroit
notre périple se poursuit nous irons à
la rencontre d'une jeune femme qui fait
de la sculpture
je ne vous en dit pas davantage